Prime Minister there's a petition on the  furniture website that has now gained  more than two million signatures asking  you to revoke article 50 are you  confident that is it is still the will  of the British people to leave the  European Union or even there's any  chance that opinion has shifted since  2016 well if you look back to what  happened in the referendum we saw the  biggest Democratic exercise in our  history we saw many people who'd either  never voted fought before or not voted  for many years turning out to vote in  that referendum and there was a clear  result that we should leave the European  Union and I think that it's important if  we want to show that we can be trusted  as politicians to respect a decision  that we gave to the people we didn't say  tell us what you think and we'll think  about it we said here's the vote what is  your decision and we will deliver on it  and I believe it is our duty as as a  government as a parliament to deliver on  that vote